so I started off by saying a little bit
about global assessments of biodiversity
then say some of the issues questions
and then I go through four case studies
so the first one was my Dookie
biodiversity action plan and we
mentioned that on Tuesday but we did a
volley transfer study there so what we
had was we split the study into eight
regions of the UK and we tried to value
or transfer values from one region to
another and see if that valuation
transfer worked the second study is a
study or review I did for Defra looking
at best practice for valuation in
developed countries or sorry in
developing countries so mostly study or
valuation techniques have been developed
for undertaken in Europe and North
America can we simply apply those in
developing countries the third one is a
study edit or is involved in in Solomon
Islands
now it's a choice experiment there and
what we tried to do in that study was
take some of the recommendations we had
in the staff for review and apply it to
the Solomon island custody' and it's
quite a neat study so you should enjoy
that and the fourth one is currently
people in Scottish agriculture college
are doing an upscaling exercise Antibes
and we've got some provisional results
so I'll show you then they're not
published yet but various scooters to
show you what what's happening in terms
of that so global assessments the first
kind of famous one was Constanza which I
think you've all heard about and the
team interim report also a musical
assessment and both of those studies
were based on upscaling studies from
local validation exercises and trying
upscale it to the rest of the world so
if we're looking at value transfer and
upscaling what does that mean so say
we've got a study here and through the
west coast of America and from that
study a tight we did a valuation and
we've worked I
value for that study site so maybe a
forest somewhere in West Coast America
then can we take that study and say okay
from that information from a study in
the West Coast America can we see
something in Connecticut about it and
you can probably think well it's all
America you've got similar incomes the
ecosystem pipe is quite similar so
there's a good chance that you can
transfer four values from west east
coast america so you've got good chance
of doing it well by if we try and
transfer this American study to Europe
well then again we've got similar
incomes to America there might be
different culture elements but some of
they and they ecosystems might be quite
similar so it chances are that you're
probably going to be reasonably
successful on that but maybe a big
question is can we take a study from
America and translate it Africa South
America particularly when incomes are
different the ecosystems might be
different and we're trying to infer
values of mechanism services from one
site to another and that may be
questionable and studies like teeb if
we've got 22 ecosystem services so then
you've me because values from northern
Europe or and say flood protection and
you've got values from South Africa
about protecting biodiversity and you
want to apply these all over the world
as well so it kind of becomes quite
complex and so my question is can values
be effective transferred across
different regions of the world
given that the the income the Social
Democrats are very different across a
world and the ecosystems are different
across the world so what we're trying to
do in the case studies explore whether
or not you can do this so in terms of
terminology value transfer is an aim of
technique where you put an estimate of a
value from policy site or to a policy
site from existing study site so a study
site is your empirical valuation study
and your policy sigh is a new one that
you're trying to infer that value the
values can be transferred you'll often
hear Farley transfer been called
benefits transfer so a lot of literature
the pharisee value transfers benefits
transfer but usually nowadays we call it
value because it can be negative values
as well as positive and benefit does
suggest positive so basically value
transfer is one site to another up
scaling or scaling up is when you do
value transferring a much worry to scale
so you're transferring a value from one
study site and you may be applying it to
also these sites across the world that
are similar to that so it's a much
larger scale and you're looking at the
entire stock of like that ecosystem so
it's it's kind of same process of
transferring values but you're just
doing a much wider scale and there's
different ways you can transfer the
value so it's what's called unit farley
transfer so well that's basically saying
is okay and west coast America vol a
forest is ten pound and I'll take that
value and move it on to the value in
East Coast America and they might adjust
it for social academic graphics but
you're just adjusting that value where a
function value transfer is you take
those regressions all the values and it
may be a regression from the study site
itself or it may be a meta-analysis so
in terms of the study site that might be
ten different studies and you can
regress for how far Lou changes against
social economic and ecological
characteristics and you and you compare
the study site stem affix with all those
and you transfer that value function so
I'll show you example of that when we do
the the t bond at the end so this
different approaches to transferring
values you just transfer the actual
values or you have a method analysis
across a bunch of studies and you use a
analysis meta-analysis equation for the
transfer over values which will adjust
it for
local circumstances so everything about
transferring one site to other how
suitable might that study site be for
the new policy site well if you look at
valuations there's a whole range of
methods so we've talked about them
yesterday so different methods might get
different types of values which is
expect be expected in the economic
theory different studies will advance
different ecosystem services so again
what you're trying to transfer from and
to might be different in terms of the
context and also in terms of policy
context and the view basing on studies
and original studies are vary in quality
so from you saw from a newer guidelines
that they reckoned that some of the old
studies were poorly designed and new
studies are maybe better because as
following your guidelines and also if
the two valley transferred as an amount
of information you need so they might be
varying quality in terms of what
information is reported for that
original study to a live value transfer
so you might have a whole stack of
potential studies but by time you
analyze them to see ver suitable you
only be able to transfer from a smaller
number of studies so you need to think
about what your policy site or your
study site studies are going to be are
they suitable for file transfer or not
so all these kind of complexities means
it's very difficult for value
transferred orally shipped to try and
account for it so if we think about
global assessments for file transfer
what are some of the key challenges to
it first of all it does actually
transfer work and they can we test it in
the controlled setting so to answer that
I'll do my Dukey biodiversity action
plan where I'm trancing transferring
values across different regions of UK
where it's based on the same survey
instrument so we should be able to value
transfer and mat setting and we can't do
in that control setting then it does
question whether they can transfer
across regions using different studies
how accurate are these transfers so
are we carrying quite close to estimates
that you'd expect or is a huge transfer
errors and the candle we'll look at some
results from that and can we be across
regions and then the second kind of
question is if we can't do value
transfer in a control setting and given
that there are only a few studies been
undertaken developing countries then if
we were to then do more studies in
development countries how should we
undertake those we'll go through some
examples of how you do valuation in
developing countries so the first case
study we talked about this a bit and
Tuesday the study on the value of echo
system services from UK biodiversity
action plan and what we did is we had
different samples across twelve regions
of Scotland Northern Ireland Wales and
nine regions of England and so we had
different sub samples of respondents
within each of those regions and just to
remind you of a choice experiment so
we're looking at different provisioning
services regulating services and
cultural services so those those were a
choice tasks we used and we reapply that
on the different regions so what we're
trying to do in looking for a
consistency farley transfer is say for
example kind of file you from a single
post OD site protective value of another
so in this case if we from our sub
sample in Northern Ireland can we say
something about how Scottish people
value those services and then we look at
maybe hi people in New York sharvani a
kind of volleys from Yorkshire be used
to protect values that people had in
Wales and so what we did is compared all
these different sites between themselves
then the second thing we looked at was
okay maybe what happens if we pull the
whole all the information from all the
other regions and transferred to
Scotland or from all the other regions
Northern Ireland and so forth so if we
pool all the information together does I
improve the value transfer
okay and in order to work out whether
the volley turns for work we work out
what's called a transfer error and what
that is is a predicted willingness to
pay so it's protected so if we're doing
this one we pull all this information
and we protect what the value in
Scotland should be so based on adjusting
it for social demographics different
levels of biodiversity between those
regions and in Scotland so we can take a
prediction of what the value should be
through the value transfer and then we
look at the observed willing to pay
which is the actual willing to pay from
the guys in Scotland we divide it by the
observed and that will give us a
percentage transfer error so how much I
is the arrow so we did this again you
won't see the numbers properly about
pool things out so these are the study
sites these ones here so this is where
the studies were undertaken so these are
12 regions and this last row is when all
the regions are pooled together so just
pulling all the information and these
are a policy sides of where it was
transferred so it's just highway up some
numbers so if we do figures from
southeast England and use that model
from data from southeast NT England
protect for East Midlands which is also
in England then we got 37% transfer
error so we're about 37% tight which
it's kind of alright it's not too bad
what about third out but if we do from
Northern Ireland and try to get east of
England then were a thousand percent out
such a huge transfer error so AVT wants
to decide to another than there are
issues and that you might end up just
having you getting it completely wrong
or you might be lucky to get right but
it's very hard to know which is right
and which is wrong if we now look at
this row here
where we're taking information from all
study sites
apart from ones were transferring to and
see if we can predict it so for most of
these sites to try and protect them
Wales we get fifty six percent error so
again that's that's kind of reasonable
and the highest error is a four hundred
percent so what that suggesting is that
if you pool information from a number of
studies the chances are you'll reduce
some of the variation so some of the
wild ones will come to light and you'll
improve the accuracy so the basic
message and this last one is saying the
percentage times that cooling
information is better I'm basing it on
one study site
I'm prey for much for most of these
examples by pooling information together
across the number study sites
means you're more likely to get better
predictions so that so key messages from
that is transfer our errors from a
single study site can't be quite large
we have you pull data from a number of
study sites then the chances are you'll
reduce the transfer errors but always
but generally so if you are doing poly
transfer is better to base it on the
number studies rather than a single one
and that kind of makes sense but the
implications of the studies that even in
this cultural setting where we had the
same questionnaire in the same country
so social demographic sar quite similar
for biodiversity types are quite similar
we're still getting problems with value
transfer and we can't do it within that
control setting then what's your chances
we can take values from America and
apply to sub-saharan Africa where it's
completely different context and so my
argument is maybe questionable so the
implications of that is if a lot of
these global assessments a lot of by
diversities in developing countries and
a lot of the issues in development
countries
it's really important we get a handle on
what's happening in these developing
countries so if it's questionable we can
transfer values from developed countries
where most valuation studies have been
undertaken then what's implications for
maybe trying to undertake valuation
development countries so the next idea
look at is this review for Defra I
undertake this Department for
Environment Food and Rural Affairs in
the UK by the extent to which valuations
been undertaking in developing countries
and also does the way we do valuation in
developed countries can we just apply it
straight to developing countries or do
we need to adjust it and what may be
best practice guidelines for doing that
so the name report was valuation of
economic and non-economic techniques for
assessing importance biodiversity in
developing countries so the aims to look
at experience of valuation development
countries look at the methodology called
practical and policy challenges of
undertaking valuation developing
countries and look at good practice
guidelines so first of all we look at
extent of studies in developing
countries and those eBRI it's called
environmental valuation resource
inventory it's held by Environment
Canada and it's basically a database of
most of the valuation studies have been
undertaken so it's a really good
database so if you're looking for
validation studies to look at if you go
to that website and I think it's free
access and from us you can come up with
study so from there we find about 200
studies hadn't looked at biodiversity
valuation in developing countries and
web of knowledge I'm sure you all know
about that do you have weapon origin
u.s. yeah so we found about 200 economic
studies and about 100 non-economic
studies if we had undertaken valuation
of biodiversity in developing countries
but if we look at valuation of
biodiversity
overall study started chimeric in the
1970s this blue line is developed
developed countries the richest
high-income countries so tons of studies
here and development countries are RVs
this is lower middle-income and
low-income countries this is
transitional economies so a tenth of his
studies we found were from developing
countries but if you look at
transitional countries these are the
poorest countries in the world then we
couldn't find any studies for on those
so the poorest countries were people
maybe we've got citizens economies and
reliant on the biodiversity pearl
subsistence livelihoods then we couldn't
find any studies there from our specific
searches that's not saying people
haven't done it but they haven't been
recorded and these two databases and
these places are probably where
biodiversity is more important to
people's livelihoods and currently
there's nothing really documented on
that so we reviewed the literature we
found and we also had three case study
five case studies that had undertaken
valuation so it's come in the best case
studies we have detailed review of the
guys who had undertook those and we also
had expert discussions with people from
around the world who'd undertaken these
studies to look at some of the
challenges so I think when we're in this
review um but developing countries cover
quite a wide range of countries so not
all these will apply to all development
countries and a lot of these apply to
the very poorest countries so the first
method cultural challenge is low levels
of literacy education and language so
following in biodiversity ecosystems
services is complex and it's hard enough
to do in the West where if people
haven't aren't educated they can't read
we haven't got any scientific knowledge
then it's quite difficult to value in
the way we do it maybe over here
so trying to the questionnaires and
interviews is difficult if people can't
read you can't just give in the question
so a kind of solution is to use
deliberative and participate two
approaches to try and collect data and
I'll show you with the Solomon example
some nylons example how we do that but
participate techniques have been
developed for getting information in
developing countries so it's very much
having detailed discussions with people
try and get them to work out what the
issues are so you're more facilitating
the information gathering and so I'll
show you examples later on another issue
what we're trying to do is get monter
evaluation of environmental goods but
some of these poorer countries have
little or no economic activity so they
don't deal with money that much not in
all or not most developing countries but
like a Solomon Islands they've only
recently had a cash economy so if you're
not used to buying things with money and
even normal goods and services then
trying to think about a state of
preference technique where you're
hypothetically giving a mind for a
hypothetical canoed oh good they're not
just gonna blow your mind it's too
difficult to do so that it's quite
difficult for people in these countries
to try think about economic values for
natural resources another thing is the
best practice guidelines for most
valuation techniques have been developed
for developed country contexts so if you
think about the noah panel review it's
suggesting for contingent valuation you
use a discrete choice referendum method
that might be okay over here but in some
developing countries you barter for a
price of goods so suddenly i beam in a
payment card or something our bidding
game might be a more appropriate way of
eliciting it because that's what they're
maybe used to doing so best practice
here is not necessarily best practice in
a development company context a
practical challenge sometimes extreme
environmental conditions so you try and
get in the rain forest and the wet
season and you just can't get anywhere
your computer crashes and so forth so
you give kind of be careful where you go
maybe more importantly
there's often the lack of capacity and
poor countries about knowledge about how
you do valuation about having people is
able to carry out interviews and it's
important you do employ for local people
because often there's a whole bunch of
local nuances which may be completely
unaware of and without local people
interpreting those nuances then you
might miss out some important stuff but
again you need to employ local people
and that means that you need to get
trained up and build capacity within the
local area but it's not all bad news
often it's easier doing surveys in
developing countries so people tend to
be happier answering questions and
they're happy to listen to new ideas and
so forth and it might be cheaper to get
interviews so you can have much larger
sample sizes for not as much current
cost so doing valuation studies here can
be quite expensive in developed
countries policy implications is maybe a
lack of awareness or sorry lack of
research capacity so it's important you
build in that capacity in developing
countries and get those people involved
lack of empirical studies which we've
already shown and what means if you're
trying to do global assessments through
upscaling then it meets value transfer
difficult if you don't have the data and
another thing you often find it's a lot
of research and development countries
extractive so what that means is you go
to look development country you do your
research you write your academic paper
and then you go home and forget about it
and what that often does can leave a bad
feeling in developing countries but what
we should be really doing is going in
there working with local communities
working with local policymakers and
building and research ideas based on
their needs not on our needs making sure
that when we get results we feed it back
into local decision-making to make sure
that they gain and benefits from the
research so kind of ethically I very
much think you should have full
engagement local communities and policy
makers to me
you search make a difference rather than
just writing your paper in science or
nature or whatever so to kind of
summarize best practice guidance often
the way if people in developing
countries think about natural resources
and Pickler people living in rural and
more tribal areas is very different to
how we in developed countries thinks so
often so like in the Solomon Islands
example they've got much closer ties to
the natural environment than we ever
have so they gather food their medicine
the building materials there so they
know their natural environment but and
that knowledge is might may be implicit
or experiential so they just kind of
know it from doing it but they might not
have a scientific understanding of it
it's not they don't understand it it
just they don't know it in scientific
terms so if we come then with all our
scientific heads then we can't just
start talking scientific terms we have
to go down to their level and get them
or get an understanding of how they
think about it and then we can relate it
back to the science so what means is
that when you trying to get people to
talk about biodiversity in ecosystem
services they might not be able to
express it clearly in a wave that we
understand so we need to try and
understand their way and we need to use
the participative techniques to try
uncover the way they understand it so it
requires a lot of work and I'll show you
in this on an example next how you might
go about doing that it's very important
that you use local researchers I can to
get an understanding or this look of
nuances and so forth both sides with
build capacity and to try and and get
this I think it's very much to try and
look at deliberative participatory
action research approaches incorporate
them into valuation and in recent years
has been a kind of move to do a lot more
or this anyway even in developed
countries but if you're looking at
complex environment
you very neat people to get full
understanding of the environmental
resource before you start valuing it
okay say so that's um can ideas we came
up with from a review and then we
thought okay it's what we're seeing is
right or should we be doing other things
so what we then decide why the
opportunity to do was to evaluation a
choice experimental validation study in
the Solomon Islands so Solomon Islands
is a community which is very poor very
based on subsistence economy very little
cash crops a little cut a little crash
so we tried to develop a deliberative
approach to valuation there and we're
gonna think out a box of how best to do
it so back into Solomon Islands so it's
kind of South East and of Indonesian
peninsular so between Australia and
Indonesia it's extremely bio diverse
culturally and in terms of biodiversity
there's lots in ten species there
there's lots of cultural biodiversity so
within the region our solar miles
there's about 80 different languages so
if you just walk over a hill the next
village is slightly or I was going to
say slightly different language
sometimes it's a very different language
so as huge cultural diversity there by
85 percent of population lives in such
systems so basically they go into the
rainforest and they get the food and all
that kind of stuff from the rainforest
they have a shifting cultivation so
they'll farm a little bit then they'll
move on to a new site and let that
forest regenerate they've got high
little custom it's kind of the custom so
it's very kind of cultural ways of doing
things and it's in the works and it kind
of can fill its society communion way of
doing things so they're very clear ways
in which we manage the forest so that's
kind of quite a strong thing for them so
so it's a very kind of primitive society
but there's a lot of pressures on them
so from particularly logging and mining
companies are trying to and and a lot of
a Solomon Islands these loggers have
come in cut down the forest and they pay
some compensation to the local
communities but your large extent
once they've can and it's going to
destroy the whole social cultural
heritage and their means of surviving so
there are big issues with this and the
community that we've engaged in called
the KOA they have realized that so they
have set up an organization to try and
fight against the loggers to try and say
well the rainforest is more important to
us than any income you might have from
logging incomes and so forth
but they have Star Trek cash crops to
cook her copra palm oil antique so there
is money going in and that is causing
some problems so once you start getting
money into an economy hasn't had any
then it does cause some cultural
problems and so forth
anise tropic population growth says more
intense occasion so they are quite
subsistence economy but there's a
growing level of pressure on them so the
region we we were looking at it's a
Kahua which is the northwest of solomon
islands and it's a region of about four
and a half thousand people so it's very
isolated there's no root or altruistic
out there you're about a day and a half
canoeing up a river then walking through
the rain forests a bit there is a little
bit money so on average people maybe
have about two hundred dollars per year
so it's only a tiny amount of money
that's just from cash crops so certainly
they're not based on the economy and
what can your associations done is I
then realized the pressures on them and
they try this protect their own cultural
heritage and their way of life
so what we're we're trying to do is from
earlier discussions with the canoe
Association we news a lot pressures and
we knew that the on the studio certain
extent how important before
was to them and what we want to try and
do is demonstrate to them much more
high-value Pater's and compare it
against the possible incomes from cash
crops so we did a choice experiment and
so it's another outline of how we
undertake our collaborative choice
experiment first we went to tribal
leaders and said well we want to have
discussions with you is that okay so he
can they need a bit negotiation or /
we've got quite good links with him so
that was not too bad then we did their
warm-up exercise so what we did was we
got them to chat about the forest and
kind of where they get food from and
what kind of products they get and then
we set them all off into the forest and
say come back with three forest products
and Leafs of trees and so forth are
things that you utilize in your everyday
life and we thought they'd come back
with maybe 25 or so different products
and I think thinking back with about 500
different plant species and that's out
of about 500 people so they've got a
great use of a forest they're using 500
different types of plants and so forth
from the forests for different uses so
if you think about how much knowledge
they have within their society about
different plants and trees and so forth
in the forests it's quite amazing and
I'm sure I think they've got a lot more
if he tried so so that exercise there
was just to kind of get feel for how
important the forest is and also give us
an understanding of a relative level of
use of that forest then we did a choice
experiment and I'll describe that in a
moment but we basically looked at four
forest attributes and we take in a
standard choice experiment but we use a
participatory add stones in the ground
and so forth I'll show you that in a
moment and then we're deliberative
element comes in is you
start having discussions with him so we
can all surround in in this kind of
village open area and we get them to
think about the valley of the wild and
subsistence good so we say okay think so
one of the attributes in the choice
experiment was a thing called GU which
is a kind of fine which is made to use
ropes and used for building and so forth
and we're saying okay think about how
much vine you get from a forest and
think about how much it might cost you
if you went into the capital and bought
that rope so think about that and think
about you're one of the big pressures as
cash crops so we're saying well think
about how much money you get from a cash
crop something about how that income
from the cash crops how you could then
use that to pay for other things that
the forest wasn't there so we're very
much came to think about the value of
the forest products and they can a
replacement cost or them we've got to
think about negative impacts of cash
crops so having money in economy was
causing lots of friction and we got them
to talk about those frictions so that
deliberation maybe went on for half a
day or so forth and then we did another
choice experiment again using his
deliberative or Sabri methods and we got
quite different results from the second
choice experiment and then what we did
we said okay is this what we could do
the quick analysis of it and fed it back
to the villagers and said okay this is
what you've told us about how important
income they think about it and reflect
on it so it's using that non extractive
method so very much taking the results
feeding it back in the villagers and
saying well what does it mean for you I
can use your search results to give a
better trajectory for your future and so
forth so that was kind of overall
framework for what we did so these are
kind of some slides from what we did so
in terms of the choice experiment so
we've got the different attributes and
different levels and so it's just laid
out in the and the floor and with new
stones to represent the levels so we
cannot say
for the finds here's three stones and
what we get them to do is moving about
so they receive it so we'd have these
different choices tasks which were kind
of set up in terms of experimental
design we talked about yesterday and the
villagers we go no no no we don't want
that then they move it stones away then
you can't discuss well what's
implications of having less of that now
we move a stone back so if we're having
you couldn't walk father to get your
vines because you've cut down the forest
what's the implications all that so it
was kind of quite fun and interactive to
do but what it meant by moving all these
different levels around in the choice
tasks what man disease guys got good
understanding of the implications of the
different scenarios so it might have
taken about half an hour to go through
one choice task or normally might take a
minute or two so it's gonna slow process
and you've got about 20 people all
fighting over it in rearranging things
it's a bit fun but what it means is
these guys are really thinking about the
implications of the different aspects of
it so the idea I think this picture here
is just some of the samples of the Leafs
it brought back so if we think about
what deliberative and participate
researchers buy it's very much about
empowering the locals to analyze or ruin
reality so what's a world like for them
and get them to think about it because
if you think about your normal life you
just you come to University you do
lectures and so forth and not just what
you do but if you step back and you
think well why do I come to lectures
here what's the reason for it what's
your motivation and you can demote your
motivations probably okay forget a nice
degree or masters and I can get a nice
job and my future will be better but you
might not really think about that every
day so it's getting these people to step
back and think about well what's
important to you and so forth
the other important thing you as the
facility outsiders of the researcher
you're very much a facilitator or not an
expert so you have to be quite humble
you say well I don't really know how
things work with you but let's think
about it you try and get them to think
about it so it's very much a
facilitation job not saying this tree is
important for you because of x y&z you
need to get them to tell you what's
important and similar learning should be
experiential so like going out in the
forest think picking a leaves are
important to you to get them the
experience rather than saying this is
what you think need to think about so in
terms of choice tasks we had four
attributes so key it's a species of fine
so it's a fine and rain forest that they
use for making ropes and so forth so
it's quite important for building and
various other things so it's a key kind
of natural resource they have and they
largely have it free from the forest and
I think at different levels one store
would mean it's only 15 minutes walk so
you'd have to walk for 15 minutes in the
forest and four stones means it's four
hours so if the rain forest is getting
destroyed or or if they're over
utilizing that resource what the finding
is they have to walk further and further
in the forest to find that resource so
those very different levels of those the
word quality I think this is saying four
stones is saying you've got good quality
drinking water so what we can drink all
year round where once so in the saying
the water quality is only good to drink
three months of a year and the rest I
miss me becoming contaminated by mining
activities or so forth then these two
are kind of come find it together so
what we're saying is the villages have
all these gardens where the can either
grow the food gardens regard grew
gardens for food that he'll consume or
they can grow coca Cardon so cash crops
so the things they can sell so well this
one here saying at the quarter of your
garden chill used for subsistence food
and the other three you
for cash crops and get some money in it
from it but you might have to buy some
food and this one 3/4 of food gardens in
1/4 Akash crops and then this different
amounts so again use experimental design
that we showed yesterday to identify
four different levels of these
attributes and from a picture we showed
before this choice that was laid out in
the ground in terms of pebbles and
that's we changed from one choice task
to the other with movie stones about and
they would come and move them around as
well and have lots of discussion and we
don't try and get settled down and say
well which of these are your preferred
options so just a kind of a bit more
participative way of doing it but kind
of similar to what we've already talked
about so if we look at results from the
first choice tire so this is gonna offer
a bit of discussion and so forth the
baseline the scenario was to get the GU
define you'd have to walk four hours but
we can prove it to walking down to 15
minutes they're willing to pay about 11
US dollars to improve water quality from
three months to having good water all
year round they're willing to pay $33
and from moving from mostly coco cash
drop gardens to food Gardens they're
willing to pay $29 so that's kind of
demonstrating that growing their own
food is actually worth quite a lot to
them so to a large extent it all seemed
to work out so that first choice tasks
they seemed to be engaging in it to see
to make it trade-offs between different
forest attributes and the Montreal Mont
and we were quite happy with that
analysis what great we can't do choice
experiments in a very subsistence type
economy but in the second one they
refuse to trade-off in money account for
money element so when we're doing it we
said he's all environmental attributes
and remember we we spend by say four
hours discussing how important the
forest was and so forth
and now when we're presenting these
choice tasks to them they're saying well
we want this where it's there's got the
food gardens we want these vines and we
we wanted we don't want to that monies
doesn't matter how much money we want
that so they stopped reading off in the
food sorry in the money cost element and
I was sorry just going back here this
$73 is about a third of her annual
income or so forth so what they're kind
of saying is well we'd be willing to pay
our entire income for these forest
products so this is my how much money or
how much money we can't give you the
forest is worth more than we can pay for
it and it took us a while to recognize
that firstly we thought there's just a
choice experiment collapsed and we're
coming and going all disappointed about
it but once we start trying to more and
more we realize that they'd through the
liberation approach they'd recognize
just the value of the products they get
from a forest so if it were to the place
of vines with having to buy rope then
they couldn't afford to buy as much rope
as he needed if we replace all the food
Gardens with cash crops the income from
a cash crop soon be enough to buy the
food from external sources so what
happened is they then began to
appreciate just how important the forest
is to them so our conclusion is that oh
and not only just the the money costs
they were also demonstrating people held
values so not only were they thinking
the cash crops won't pay for all the
products we want but they're also
realizing that by minting in the forest
in the best condition as you can then
that'll ensure that for all the kids in
future generations will have enough food
and products from forest so when they're
describing why they came to light
position it wasn't just for them but
they had very strong belief that they
needed to protect the forest for the
future generations and that wasn't going
to be the only way they secured
future if they maintain the forest so
that was quite a profound statement from
them the other important element they
were discussing about why they can trade
off money with all these social culture
ailments so not only were their
traditional products the game from a
forest but all that kind of traditional
cultural practices so they kind of
worship before it's worship the rivers
and so forth
so all the kind of cultural heritage is
linked in with that forest and they
start cutting down that forest they're
going to lose all that heritage and
again they recognize importance of that
cultural heritage so there was kind of
real realization or just how
interconnected their lifestyles were to
the rainforest and you couldn't replace
all those benefits cultural benefits and
and so forth with any monthly income so
it was quite a quite profound kind of
finding that we got from there so if we
look at kind of some lessons learn from
that so they participate deliberative
approaches to undertaken valuations so
using all these kind of stones and big
discussions overcome many of the
practical issues for valuations or
they're illiterate so overcome some of
those illiteracy problems and so forth
so it was good for that and those
deliberative approaches very much drawn
action research action researchers has
been developed to try and work out
information from developing countries
but then make sure that information is
used to develop for future future
policies we very much looked at our
action research the other thing is we're
we're taking a group paced approach so
normally when you're - in valuation
studies you ask individuals how much are
you willing to pay how much you will be
paid and yes assuming that people are
you tell theory and utility maximizers
so what you're trying to do is maximize
your own benefit what you're doing is
maximizing your own benefit and we
aggregate it out
but and these more subsistence societies
it's very much group decision-making so
Isaac village you'll all sit down
together and they'll work out what
they'll do in terms of future rainforest
so their decision-making processes group
decisions and there's very much social
values so people work on the social
value context so they're very much
decisions are made for society as a
whole rather than their individualism
over here so again you the way we
undertook it was a group process and
there are big issues about how you
aggregate group values but what's
interesting now we've in the UK we're
started thinking about social values so
rather than just on create group values
do people have a different set of social
values so if you think about climate
change I might feel that climate change
is something that society should be
addressing so my social value for that
is we need to reduce our impact and
climate change
but if you look at what I've do I end up
flying around the world and I think well
actually my individual choices I'm not
really meeting my social values and
they're interesting questions or how you
interact individual values and
activities with what people think a
societal group and how can you convert
people's individual activities to poor
of a social group benefits so that's a
link which is kind of starting to a
marriage and valuation literature the
hands-on exercises the great fun to do I
think people really learn from it and
when they're moving your stones around
and so forth they're really think about
the consequences of with different
policy options and maybe we should start
doing these type of things when we do
valuation and develop countries so again
there's starting to look at those type
of things I need well-trained local
facilitators so out of 18 different
villages I think over six different
languages although generally they all
spoke pidgin
but so you need the local facilitators
to be able to communicate with them so
you couldn't come there and learn six
different languages to do that research
but half of people the villagers could
speak pidgin English and there's lots of
translation going on but also you need
to look at facilities to kind of
interpret people's choices to account
for those local nuances so we don't know
the traditions and the Solomon Islands
but the locals will and having those
facilities will maybe be able to help
you better understanding of those issues
ah nothing people in the subsistence
economy where they're maybe not used to
dealing with money can work out choice
tasks so because maybe they're not used
to dealing with money if we're not
educated but they have a cognitive
ability to trade off these different
choice tasks so a choice experiment type
activity isn't beyond them you just
might have to adjust it for their
context context social learnings got
considerable impact on value outcome so
what that's meaning is through a
deliberative approach we had half a
day's discussion about this choice to
ask and what the forest means and
through that deliberation they developed
a better understanding of our own
realities so there was kind of social
learning and that effect of a choice tie
so then they become more aware that
forest was more important to them than
any money so well that may be say these
values are maybe not preformed so and
and it becomes a big issue for valuation
what are we trying to value is it me
going to ask you just now how much you
value biodiversity from your current
knowledge or do I make you informed
about what by adversity means for you
and then ask you as an informed person
what value means to you so and again
it's something which I we're starting to
research in the developed country
context is a we're value in complex
goods that people have a good practice
in dealing with
the issue we need social learning and
desire construct preferences or does it
better perform preferences so we take
example of the mountain biking one means
a mountain biker I know exactly what
type of mountain biking experience I
want because I do it every weekend so
I've got a very clear idea of what my
values are where if you're thinking
about biodiversity ecosystem services I
don't really trade in that so I might
not have thought about it before
so do I have properly foreign
preferences and it's maybe only through
that discussions and starting to think
about it too I really understand what I
want and what I don't want but does it
mean it we're influencing people
decisions and I think the conclusion
from that is if you have got social
learning what you need to do is when you
portrayed your results from your study
is you say these are the values of
people who have thought about it they
may not be representative to public who
hasn't thought about those ideas but
this is a valuation from in the forum
public I think the other element there
is for the biodiversity action plan
project we did and if you remember we
talked about it we had some films or we
have the choice tasks then we had a
couple films and biodiversity and
ecosystem services and lots of
discussion and did another choice tasks
and what we've found them those and and
also we had two months later we
contacted people again and said ok now
you've lived with this idea of
biodiversity ecosystem services your
normal life here's another choice tasks
and see how you now think about it and
what we found is the actual values
didn't change but people's standard
errors and those values got smaller so
people were more aware of what their
values were we're doing it naively there
was lots of errors so people were really
thinking their choices so what that
suggests it's social learning can
actually improve valuation without
necessarily affecting those valuations
but I think it's something that people
have only started looking at and we
maybe need more research on those ideas
the last thing I want to do is try and
finish off with this team quantitative
assessment so in the early stages of T
they tried that kind of value transfer
exercise and to look at the overall
value and with the tip exercise we can
review different methods of how you do
it we can expanded the data base or
valuation studies and currently led by
people in Scotch agriculture college
they're doing an upscaling to try and
work out the value so I don't think it's
not properly finished so this is kind of
preliminary results and it has me
published but it's an example of
upscaling and within the teep context so
what they're trying to do is estimate a
global benefits of a series of global
change scenarios so if we talked a whole
bunch of kind of experts and try to work
out what is the future of the world
going to be in the next 10 and 40 years
or so so the method they identify these
possible future scenarios for the world
and also it's more about that in a
moment then they use this biophysical
models glo-bo
well that day there's look at the impact
of each future change scenarios on
biodiversity ecosystem services and then
they use Farley transferrin upscaling to
look at the economic impact all the
changes those scenarios on these
biophysical ecosystem services so in
terms of change scenarios there's nine
scenarios so looking at agriculture
production so given that plant
technology and so forth life stopped
breathing then we can in next so this is
the 2015 time scale so they reckon we
can increase yields from crops by 40%
and livestock by 20% so we can increase
the output for my culture so I was the
FIR
scenario so more efficient ways of
logging first and so forth
expanding their two protected areas from
current 14% to either 20% or 50% so
having much more protected area
management more of the rights or reduce
emitted missions from deforestation and
forest aggregation so really meant that
read increase in bioenergy so from 0.5
to 4 million kilometer squares for by
mass production and changing global
diets to healthier diet and substituting
meat from to protein so these are 9
scenarios these policymakers and thought
could happen in the future and possible
ways of reducing impacts so then what
they did was use a couple of models from
the complex systems models to look at
the impact of those scenarios and also
look at other other change so looking at
population growth back economic growth
and these are they scenarios to predict
to the area's different eye culture
yields and so forth and they fed it into
its image 2.4 model and that kind of
took all this information looking at
land use changes and so forth and coming
it's a big systems models and you take
information from databases from around
the world and different regions of the
world and the output of that so things
like emissions and so forth be faster
than this globe io3 model and that's
looking at different drivers and harmful
change looking different effects and it
looks at the indicators on biodiversity
so things like mean species index
abundance and so forth so basically by
combining these two models they got
these different scenarios for the future
so how world might be by 2050 went
through all these systems and work out
what the impacts are in biodiversity so
an impact on biodiversity and ecosystem
services
then what they tried to do is or based
on those impacts are changes in
ecosystem services biodiversity they try
to look at what the value of that value
those changes and to do that they drew
on the TPA base so from a teat database
they came up whether it was about five
hundred studies or Valley points that
they utilize I think that there's a lot
more in at EPA base but not all are
suitable for valuation so they can look
at different habitats so their analysis
was in different biomes so from tropical
rainforests coal reefs and so forth so
it looked across different biomes and
these numbers here later the number of
studies that are finding those biomes so
currently there's lots of studies in
coastal wetlands tropical rainforest
coral reefs and Inland Wetlands and
temperate forests and some like last
year's and so forth there's no real
Studies on so if we kind of only
utilized those biomes where there was
good data so it's no point trying to do
its analysis originally one day a point
because it's probably have huge errors
and they've got four different regions
again so it's different information from
different regions and they were doing a
kind of spatial mapping a GIS mapping of
all this so looked at different regions
and they also looked at 22 different
ecosystem services so had valleys for
different services so what they then did
was got all this information so these
data points and they did I can a
meta-analysis all those data so what
you're trying to do is look at how the
value so your dependent variable is the
value so it was like dollars per hectare
per year I converted to a standard 2007
so all the values from all these
different studies were converted to a
standard valuation unit and they request
that value against a whole range of
different things so how does a value
compare to the country it's in how the
value compared to the
the meeting come from that country how
does the value change compared to how
close it is to an urban population so
these are the kind of meta analysis
where span of variable is a value these
are for temperate forests and tropical
rainforests so for example if you look
at here natural log of fear the forest
within 50 kilometers of study site is
negative so what that means is as you go
closer to study site then the values get
greater because there's more people
benefiting it from it so they've got a
whole bunch of variables that they did
they regress the values from and then in
order to upscale it what you do is you
get information from around the world
and say okay if I'm looking at topical
rainforests and from its meta-analysis
which summarizes maybe 25 different
surveys and you've got the social
economic the environmental attributes on
the on this regression then you can look
at it and say okay if I'm applying this
to Southeast Asia then I multiply the
coefficient by the mean income of
Southeast Asia I multiply it by the
number of people within 50 kilometers
and so forth so allows you to predict
the value for that specific region so
they can it did that and here's results
from temperate rainforests and this is
for the future case scenario of 20% of
the ecosystem will be protected and this
is 50% protected so we've got number of
sites so these are different regions of
the world so subside in Africa South
Asia and so forth so these are different
sites through the JVs model or that
particular ecosystem pipe we've got how
that area we change so through those
systems models that work out how much so
that area we change in terms of its land
use and so forth and then by applying
that change with
upscaling the follow transfer function
you can't devolve you or me value per
hectare than the annual value so those
were results from temperate forest the
similar things in tropical rainforests
so again they're trying to work out
based on the scenario of changes in the
level of protected area management this
is how we'd affect it and gives you an
idea
they kind of did kind of roughs spatial
map so if the area of protection of
protected area was increased from 14 to
20 percent then all the red so in South
America that we call the loss in value
so somewhere between rhino bite say 250
billion US dollars would be the decline
in value there and the reason for that
if you protect the Amazon then it means
that people can't log or have
agricultural activities so by having
increased protection it means that
you're as an opportunity cost loss from
that forest where in developed countries
generally it's fine that we've got
higher protected areas then that's going
to have more benefit and if you look at
50 percent area protected then generally
around the world and means that that
would reduce people's welfare throughout
the world
so you're restricting what they can do
in terms of food production and so forth
and so they've got graphs like this for
I all those nine different scenarios
future scenarios and I think it depends
on the level of accuracy you're needing
so me as an academic
looking at value transfer I'd be hoping
to get within say 50 percent transferred
errors so something which is kind of
meaningful or within the level of
magnitude but maybe for these global
upscaling what you want to do is try and
generally demonstrate what the impact
might be you might be a little bit more
relaxed on the size of errors as often
with these if you're pulling together
lots of survey
then a lot of those errors cancel each
other right anyway so I think it does
provide useful information if you can
demonstrate the economic impact of these
Global Change models and by creating
numbers it does lead something for a
discussion numbers night will not be a
hundred percent accurate but as we saw
from those graphs we see that in some
areas of the world so South America it
might have a negative impact where in
Europe and North America might have a
positive impact and those kind of
changes positive or negative are
probably quite robust so it depends what
you want to do and if it's enough to
stimulate discussion then that's a lot
better and having new information at all
where you can't have you've got nothing
discuss so I think in that context it's
quite good but I think we have got a
long way in terms of trying to improve
valuation transfer and pyruvates a lack
of valuation studies but some of it and
the lack of validation studies have been
developed directly to feed in value
transfer and that will improve over time
and this may be we're only started doing
value transfer and we might find better
ways of doing in the future